One of the greatest wrestlers of all time
just got sucker punched.
When you see the words
"Hulk Hogan sex tape,"
you have that moment before you decide
whether or not to click it.
Hogan's $100 million lawsuit
over a tape that was posted online
by the website  Gawker.
It's the first celebrity sex tape case
to go to trial.
It put Internet privacy
in a battle against freedom of the press.
Gawker  becomes convinced
that somebody with a different agenda
is financing this lawsuit.
Billionaire Peter Thiel,
a co-founder of PayPal,
is secretly paying the expenses
of Hulk Hogan's legal fight.
A story about his sexual orientation was
published nine years before this lawsuit.
This is personal.
He's doing this
because he wants to bring  Gawker  down.
We're gonna open up those libel laws,
and we're going to have people sue you
like you never got sued before.
Donald Trump, Peter Thiel,
and other billionaires...
have tried to undercut freedom of speech.
Sheldon Adelson bought
the  Las Vegas Review-Journal.
What he did was take off the boards
people who might reveal something
that he doesn't like.
Billionaires are proclaiming,
"We are more powerful than the truth."
This is a moment of real definition
for the press.
You are fake news.
Journalism is worth protecting.
If we lose that,
we've lost what America stands for.
We have to fight harder
and smarter than ever.
Here's a message to the White House:
you keep lying,
we're going to keep reporting.
The president believes the press
is a threat to the country.
- Alternative facts are not facts.
- He thinks democracy is outmoded.
Money can't silence the media.
-We're talking about the truth.
-Can you turn the microphone off?